hey
folks um awesome to be here um really
cool to be on the same stage as
bology um so we have a parallel
Financial system with salana it's kind
of a pun Solana it has a parallel
virtual machine that I think we're
famous
for and our goal is to make Finance open
and better and um we like to we have
this kind of silly tagline only possible
on salana
um it's possible in a lot of places but
what I want to kind of hone in on is
that what we've really kind of got to
work really well is we can show that
execution like the thing that that's
really really hard to prove is actually
better on a open decentralized system
and it's going to be mechanically better
like by every measurable objective
measurable thing performance latency
cost it's going to be better running in
a decentralized system and if that's
true it's inevitable that it's going to
win there's just never going to be a
time in the future where we believe that
centralized kind of financial systems
are going to win um so what are we kind
of talking about and I think uh when you
look at like the Wells Fargo page there
is a bajillion different kind of
features that they're offering and
they're all integrated into the bank
they're offered by the Cent giant
Central company that's too big to fail
and um without really much help from
myself or anyone working on the salana
protocol there's like 50 different
companies that have basically built
every one of these features and all of
these companies are all in the same
blockchain right right running in the
same state machine and when you interact
with them you can actually interact with
all of them in one transaction at a
fraction of a scent literally one
hundredth of a penny and uh you can talk
to all of them at the same time time in
one Atomic State transition and like
execute and you wouldn't even know and
that's really really cool it's because
they're all sharing the same network
State uh but like
literally yeah you don't have to laugh
terrible terrible joke but like when you
compare this to like a company like
Robin Hood you have 20 like you have
nine different companies that have to
touch your trade each one of them takes
a few bips off that trade it takes
multiple dat for the actual financial
information to go from when you clicked
a button to like being reconciled at a
settlement facility that finally
actually says that yeah ownership of
something changed on salana you got like
a $20 order can go through what is that
like eight different markets run by
different protocols run by different
companies there's no fees between any of
them right you have one giant
transaction that's completely composed
and executed immed immediately um and
this actually scales the way you think
of it is not that it scales to a larger
number right because if we go to like a
million dollars it's obvious that you
can go and talk to nine companies to
settle a million dollars but this scales
the other way you can actually shrink
this order down to like 20 cents and
it'll still go through four different
companies like and that's crazy to think
about like a micro payment that touches
four different OTC desks like that would
be insane right in in normal Finance but
that totally doable in one giant highly
optimized State
machine um so this company code they
literally built a product for developers
to build micro payments when you like
charge a credit card right like the
minimum fee if you ever go to a store
that's like worried about credit card
fees they'll say you got to buy at least
$5 worth of goods or you got to pay at
least 25 cents extra for a credit card
well like these folks can do micro
payment totally settled between the user
without any intermediaries for like sub
25 cent payments literally sub 1 cent
payments and it's instant like as soon
as you click it it happens and in a lot
of ways the stuff is going to be kind of
transparent to a lot of users it's not
like Shopify or all these great
applications that like Merchants have
gotten to use are just going to somehow
disappear or be outcompeted it's very
likely that these folks that build great
products are just going to start
adopting these under the hood and when
you think from Shopify perspective it's
a company that's a technology company
they don't really care how Finance Works
under the hood they just wanted to work
and they want to deliver great products
to to their users so like all this stuff
is kind of happening already and is
being and like the competition with
regular Finance by decentralized
companies is happening and in my point
of view we're
winning and we can actually tackle all
possible venues ref Finance exists from
like credit for credit desks they're
doing trading or like actual credit for
consumers um this one's like a probably
the hardest and kind of last Bion
because figuring out identity and credit
risk and credit worthiness on chain is
still pretty hard and like execution and
speed is probably the the easiest
problem to solve there or at least the
the the lowest margin
problem um but when all this stuff comes
together get like really unexpected
things happen uh this is probably one of
my favorite examples I spent most of my
career at qualcom working on mobile
phones dealing with giant carriers like
Verizon and this is a startup they're
using cryptoeconomics to deploy 5G cells
that are token incentivized so it's we
call it deepened decentralized
physically uh incentivized
networks and they are able to offer
consumers a $5 data plan so you have a
five you have a cell phone you sign up
for helium looks and works just like a
normal mobile carrier and you're paying
five bucks for data but under the hood
it is running on salana it's using nfts
to track all the hotpots it's issuing
helium tokens to every little hotspot
around the city that can track where
there's more users on one block and
offer more to more tokens there and
within a day somebody will go pop a
hotspot there without having to go talk
to the city get licensing to put up a
tower and like do all the stuff that uh
Verizon would need to
do and these are all giant you know like
a giant list of every possible thing you
can have in finance and in ways that are
almost non expected like like deploying
physical networks for for c for cell
towers for for cell your networks um all
of these things are Financial um and
they being built in the ecosystem by a
bunch of developers that are you know
working independently but they're all
composed together over the same common
protocol so that's the message parallel
Finance that's being built and it's
going to win thank you
guys